Hand over the Child, Mando!
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my Mandalorian episode 5
video we'll call this the fanservice
episode because there were a bunch of
fanservice drops so I'll explain all the
Easter eggs and there was a big a big
post-credit scene if you're new to the
channel I'm doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're also doing a merch
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the episode on the video
obviously careful for spoilers from the
episode if you have not seen it yet but
we do top 10 and Easter eggs
starting with number 10 the title of the
episode the gunslinger more overtly
based on Western tropes than samurai
tropes but traditionally a lot of
Western films themselves were ripoffs of
earlier samurai films so technically
it's kind of the same thing but most of
the way the plot plays out is based on
the John Wayne movie The Searchers one
of his final movies where he has to team
up with a rookie on a mission involving
a lot of Native Americans represented by
the sand people in this episode based on
his knowledge of the sand people's
culture I'm assuming that he's been to
Tatooine before he also referenced womp
rats which are native to Tatooine you
would only know about those if you'd
been to Tatooine but number 9 they
opened the episode with the Mandalorian
on the run from another bounty hunter in
what looks like a fighter similar to the
Naboo star fighters from Phantom Menace
they were a lot a lot of Phantom Menace
Easter eggs in this episode also a New
Hope mostly in a little bit of Return of
the Jedi just because we are on Tatooine
the bounty hunter throws his own line
Adam I can bring you in warm or bring
you in cold to which the Mandalorian
replies that's my line after destroying
him love baby Yoda's reaction to the
rollercoaster of evasive maneuvers that
they were doing trying to get away from
that fighter just bouncing all over the
place if you look he's actually sitting
inside a protective case that you would
put valuables and inside that seat he's
not sitting in the seat itself he's
sitting in a case that's sitting on the
seat but number 8 welcome back to
Tatooine I hope you like sand even
before they revealed that it was
actually Tatooine which was later in the
episode you see this giant sand based
planet you instantly think of Tatooine
and when they land in a very Mos Eisley
looking spaceport you just start to
assume this is probably going to be
Tatooine the actual docking bay that he
lands the Razr Creston is docking bay 35
the docking bay from a new hope that the
Millennium Falcon was in was docking bay
number 94 so it's not the exact same
docking bay but man they start rolling
it out with the fan service from Phantom
Menace so number seven he walks down the ramp of the ship and Anakin's repair
droids from Phantom Menace just pop up
like they've still been around this
entire time Darth Vader has since long
become a force ghost in this new woman
who's now servicing this area has just
taken them on as her own
I think the funnier thing though is it's
the minute that they pop up he shoots
them instantly not only because he
doesn't like droids but it's also them
winking from behind the camera taking a
subtle dig at Phantom Menace like oh
this is a silly thing we're shooting it
because we don't like silly things that
much you meet the first special guest
it's Amy Sedaris
you probably recognize her from a whole
bunch of other things she's an amazing
comedian but her performance within the
episode is totally a little bit
different than what you would expect in
Star Wars you'd expect someone to be
that silly and something like the
holiday special but in a traditional
Star Wars film you don't expect that
kind of comedy as he walks into town to
search for some work so that he can get
some credits to pay for the repairs she
calls him a womp rat he walks through
town past a bunch of stormtrooper
helmets that are impaled on spikes while
she's waiting for him to get back she
starts playing a game of sabacc cards
with the other droids when all of a
sudden number 6 baby Yoda makes the
crate dragon noise from a new hope that
obi-wan made when he was trying to save
Luke from the sandpeople you hear this
crazy screeching sound they think that
it's some monster on the ship but then
out walks tiny little baby Yoda it's a
bit of a misdirect because she's a nice
person she just wants to take care of
him and that's kind of what they do with
him for the episode there wasn't a whole
lot of baby Yoda throughout this episode
number 5 though
welcome to the Mos Eisley cantina there
are a couple of Eevee 99 droids Manning
the bar just like the one in Jabba's
palace and you find out that it is
pretty much the cantina from a new hope
because a lot of the aliens from the
cantina scene in a new hope are in this
scene I can't remember what kind of
alien this ant looking one is but there
was a praying mantis which is about as
close as we got to insect in the
original cantina scene this is me loss
from a new hope
he's a Saarland lizard like species he
was also in the cantina scene from a new
hope in they have a very Greedo shot
first moment when the new character Toro
Callahan asks the mando for help and
tracking down his new mark so that he
can gain entry into the bounty hunters
guild in surprise surprise it winds up
being ming-na turns out she wasn't
actually in the episode for that much
people might complain about that which
I'll totally understand they kind of
sold it as if she's going to be a much
bigger character and she was really only
around for a brief cameo her name is
Fenic Shan she was an assassin who
worked for the Hutt syndicate Black Sun
crimson dawn a lot of the other criminal
syndicates in the galaxy they just tried
to set her up like this really badass
hunter that'll take down anybody
that comes after her and her costume
kind of looks like an inquisitors
costume but he references out beyond the
Dune Sea which is a line taken directly
from a new hope that's where Luke says
old Ben Kenobi lives out beyond the Dune
Sea not anymore as of the events of this
episode because he's a force ghost most
of the people including Anakin Skywalker
Darth Vader have already turned into
force ghost when this is happening when
the mando goes back to the docking bay
to check on baby Yoda there's a gonk
droid walking behind him they get to
karelians speeder bikes to take off on
but you noticed that they take the time
for the rookie to get a clear look at
baby Yoda
who he thinks is kind of weird but he
doesn't think too much of it at the time
until he meets Ming nas character who
tells him what happened to the mando and
why he's wanted by the bounty hunters
guild they stopped for a couple Tusken
Raiders they do the exact same bit from
a new hope with Luke Skywalker checking
them out with the binoculars and then
finding out they're also right behind
him big surprise jump scare the mando
explains a little bit about their
culture how they think they're the
locals and everyone else was trespassing
like I said this is another one of those
references to that John Wayne film The
Searchers with the Native Americans but
he's able to communicate with them using
sign language that not quite as crazy as
they're portrayed during a New Hope or
during Attack of the Clones when Anakin
Skywalker finds out that they captured
his mother and then he slaughters the
entire village of them I got all the
women and the children too
since the movies came out they tried to
use the comics the books the other
animated series to expand on the sand
people's culture in their race to make
them seem less like savages and more
like an actual culture but then number
four the Mandalorian in the rookie
versus Ming nas character she sets a
trap for them using
another bounty hunter that she just
killed who had come for her in his due
back they find out she's using an MK
modified rifle which is the same kind of
rifle that the Senate guards used during
the prequels and you'll learn a little
bit more about how his best car armor
protects him he says that it's effective
at certain ranges so at this range yes
it'll totally protect me whereas the
idea is that his previous armor would
not have protected him he's also able to
soak another full blast in the chest at
much closer range too so it just gives
you an idea for how strong the armor is
now when they're making their move on
her in the middle of the night using
those flash grenades it's also a bit of
a reference to the searchers there's a
lot of nighttime scenes that look
amazing the way they filmed them during
that old western film obviously they
didn't have flash grenades during that
movie but they did have a lot of action
scenes that took place at night when
they're able to capture her she
references Navarro as the planet that
they were on in the first couple of
episodes we finally learned which one
that was there was a lot of confusion
early on because they never told us what
it actually was but me Knotts character
tries to start turning the rookie
against the man doe by telling him about
what happened back on Navarro with baby
Yoda this is amazing bounty on him and
the child that he took if you bring them
back you'll be legendary I can help you
do it she also references a job that she
had in Mos Espa that she was heading to
and she'll give him some of the money if
he takes her there Mos Espa is also the
city from Phantom Menace where Anakin's
podrace took place but number 3 the
rookie kills her and then goes back to
get the bounty on baby Yoda there was a
big turn with his character in this
moment he comes across as more
diabolical than you would expect whereas
earlier he portrayed himself as a little
bit greener behind the ears oh you know
I'm a rookie I don't know anything about
this I totally need your help to take
her down the man who eventually makes it
back with the Dewback sees what happens
then goes back to town and then number
two the Mandalorian versus the rookie
they have a bit of a gunslinger standoff
moment but the mando is able to take him
down using another flash grenade the
same trick they used on Ming nas
character earlier in the episode this
scene is also a bit of a reference to
the way The Searchers movie ended with
John Wayne once they were able to take
him down she tells the droids to throw
the body in Beggar's Canyon another
reference to a new hope that is the
mando and baby Yoda eventually head off
planet number 1 the big post-credits
scene so this is ending scene of someone
wearing Spurs inspecting meand Oz
body that just walks up you don't see
them pan up the body you just hear the
Spurs and you see the boots there were a
lot of people this sporting I saw it
didn't quite recognize what was going on
here didn't understand what the Spurs
were supposed to imply so when he walks
up the reason why they only focus on the
Spurs is because they're Boba Fett's
Spurs the design of his character was
originally based on Clint Eastwood's man
with no name character who when he walks
his Spurs will chink and make that same
sound you can even hear Boba Fett's
Spurs chink in Empire Strikes Back when
he's walking around and nobody else is
speaking on top of him so because this
takes place five years after Return of
the Jedi I'm assuming that Boba Fett has
since climbed out of the mouth of the
Sarlacc which is something from legends
if you never read any of the legends
like tales from Jabba's palace there is
a lot of Boba Fett stuff that happens
during those books they also cover a lot
of both at post original trilogy in the
dark empire comics from Dark Horse which
are also legends and technically not
canon anymore but in those stories he
eventually did escape the mouth of the
Sarlacc repaired his armor a little bit
and then went on to continue pursuing
Han Solo to get revenge on him but
because Boba Fett is showing up now
inspecting ming-na he probably also has
a tracking fob for the kid and is
probably hunting for the Mandalorian and
baby Yoda now so they're hyping up a
Mandalorian versus Boba Fett finale
potentially although I do think that
there are bigger villains like they'll
have their gunslingers standoff moment
but because of all the Clint Eastwood
man with no name references it sounds
like with Boba Fett's appearance now
they're doing a little bit of the good
the bad and the ugly with I guess Boba
Fett playing the Lee Van Cleef bad
character in the mando obviously being
the good Clint Eastwood character so
everybody just posts all your reactions
in the comments let me know if you
spotted any Easter eggs in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video I'll
probably do a new Boba Fett video in the
next couple of days because there's just
so much that we have to talk about now
that Boba Fett is part of the
Mandalorian series I never expected them
to include him in this just because he's
been in the Sarlacc chillin this whole
time but while you wait for everything
click here for my new baby yoda video
and click here for my Mandalorian
episode 4 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!